90%的人做AI长视频总是翻车 根本原因不是模型不够强 而是因为用了错误的方法 两端15秒衔接的时候 色彩突变，卡顿，甚至动作突然断掉 这些问题我全踩过了直到我把传统电影剪辑的方法搬到AI视频中 从那之后不管视频升成多少段 都能像一个镜头拍出来的一样丝滑
那今天我就把这套AI长视频 丝滑连贯三部法 手把手教会你 老规矩所有的步骤和提示词都放文档啦
1 学会切换颈别和角度 我们先来看一下这两个案例
是不是后面的衔接比前面的更丝滑 接下来呢我就教会你是用
这种丝滑的衔接方式 之所以你剪辑的视频怪怪的
就是因为你把相似的角度和景别连在了一起 那么怎么解决呢 和我一起操作
这里我以LibTV作为实操带练 方法适用于任何AI影视工具
点击右下角截取视频的尾帧 点击图片 选择上方的九宫格 多机位九宫格 点击生成
这个时候我们就可以看到有多个画面 选择我们想要的画面作为下一个视频的首帧
关键点来了 选择画面的时候有一个原则
要么选择不同的景别 要么选择不同的角度
这样通过画面的切换 我们就能很巧妙地把两段视频自然衔接在一起
这也是电影剪辑的技巧之一 我们来看下成片
那恭喜你学会了第一个画面衔接的技巧
已经可以做成连贯的长视频了
接下来我们学习一个进阶的高级技巧
在动作中衔接
我们来看这两段衔接的画面
片段一
片段二
是不是第二段更丝滑
这个就是更高级的做法
故意让两段视频保留一段相同的动作衔接在一起
我们只需要在视频中找到女生拿起咖啡起始动作
点击右下角截取当前针
点击刚才截取针的画面
选择上方的九宫格
多机位九宫格
选择一个有景别和角度变化的图片
接下来我们不要用这个图片生成喝咖啡
而是在提示词中写女生继续抬起咖啡杯
举到嘴边轻轻喝一口
随后放下咖啡杯
注意这里的关键词继续抬起
而不是开始喝咖啡
因为我们需要让动作产生重叠
生成完成后把两个动作对齐
然后把剪辑点放到动作进行到一半的位置
你会发现即使已经切换视频
观众也几乎察觉不到
因为咖啡杯始终在沿着同一个运动轨迹在移动
这里其实利用了人类的视觉暂流现象
人脸在看到画面后
影像会在视网膜停留约0.1到0.2秒
在角色或者物品正在运动的瞬间切镜头
前后阵的运动轨迹会被大脑自动衔接
根本察觉不到断片了
最后再教大家一个终极方法
不要硬序长镜头
用分镜阻接镜头
在真正的电影中
导演会把故事拆成多个镜头
既然工具一次只能生成15秒
那我们就在故事版阶段
把镜头衔接成能够15秒之内完成的小剧情
比如女生在列车发车之前送出文件的短片
我们可以把剧本上传给AI
点击加号
选择脚本
点击生成
这样我们就得到了一个不要有时间的分镜头脚本
我们只需要每次选择15秒以内的脚本组接在一起
比如第一段前四个镜头是4秒加3秒加3秒加4秒一共是14秒
正好在15秒之内
再把人物设定图和场景参考图同时位给AI
这样就可以得到第一段
第二段
第三段
每个片段只负责一个剧情阶段
即更容易生成
组接起来也超过了15秒
更有电影节奏
我们来看下效果
所以你会发现
真是限制AI长视频制作的不是15秒
而是你在应序长镜头
电影本来就不是一镜到底
而是靠镜头组接完成叙事
学会切换景别和角度
学会在动作中衔接
再用分镜拆开剧情
当你学会像导演一样设计每一个镜头怎么样接下去
你就能真正创作出属于自己的电影
我是AI界人民教师一番
还想聊点啥
我们下期接着学